字幕: Hiroyuki Sugiura
校正: Harue Mori
皆さん
ここにある水
ある重さを例えているんですけれども
何かわかりますか？
ちょっと難しいですよね
私くらいの背格好の方の
体重の４分の１の重さの水です
２リットルのペットボトルなので
男性の方だったらあと３本くらい
追加する感じになりますかね
どうですか 皆さん
ご自身の体重の４分の１の重さ
イメージできましたか？
では 想像してみてください
その体重の４分の１の重さの
おもりを背負って
１リットルの水筒を首からさげて
30分歩かないと あなたの職場に
学校に着きません
人によっては40分の人もいます
50分の人もいるかもしれません
着いてから その日の日課が始まります
そのような日常が
ずっと続くと言われたら
そのまま受け入れることができる人は
いるでしょうか
「まあ言われたら仕方がない
全然できるよ」という方—
よろしければ挙手していただけますか
全然いない
全然いないんですね
本当に皆さん
何か変えなくてはいけない
何か変えてほしいと思う方が
動き出す方が
ほとんどではないかと思います
現在 小学１年生の平均体重が
20キロ程度であることに対して
毎日学校へ持って行く荷物の総量が
５キロを超えることは
稀ではありません
そう 体重の４分の１の重さです
このように１年生の荷物量の平均が
６キロを超えるというデータもあります
５キロ ６キロの荷物
大人でも嫌ですよね
でも この荷物は
学年が上がるごとに増え
高学年になると10キロを超える荷物を
持っている子もいるんです
ここにある水
全部を背負っている子もいるはずです
ゆとり教育が終わり
教科書のページ数が年々増加しています
小学生のお子さんが
６年間で習う教科書の総ページ数は
平成17年度から比べると
なんと７割も増えているんです
しかも サイズが大きくなり 紙が良くなり
とにかく重くなっています
なぜ 私がこのようなことを
お話しするのかというと
私の娘が 小学校に入学して３日で
ランドセルを背負うと
「肩が痛い」と言いはじめ
そのあとも
「荷物が重い」「入りきらない」
「使いにくい」と不満が続いたんです
改めて見てみると
子どもが毎日使うものとしては
おかしいんじゃないかと思うところが
たくさんあることに気がつきました
もちろん
一般的な 高価な
とても良いランドセルです
ランドセルは 子どもが毎日使うもの
つまり イコール「日用品」のはずですよね
皆さんは ご自身のカバンを選ぶ時に
どのように選びますか？
お出かけ用に
ちょっといいブランドバッグ
仕事用に
書類がたくさん入るバッグ
旅行用に
とにかく軽いバッグ
毎日使うものだったら
更に機能も気になるはずです
飲み物は すぐに出したいから
ペットボトルが入れられるようなポケットが
外側に付いていると便利だなとか
鍵とか財布は すぐ出せる位置に
ポケットが欲しいなとか
リュックだったら 背中が暑いだろうから
メッシュになっているといいなとか
肩ベルトを固定するバックルが
付いてると楽だよなとか
お子さんが使うランドセルはどうでしょう
まず 毎日使う「日用品」のはずですよね
たくさん歩きもします
皆さん ランドセルは
どのように選んでいるんでしょうか
みんなが使っているから
まず 大前提に皮や合皮のランドセル
こう答える方がほとんどです
私もそう
当たり前に思って選びました
価格は 平均で５万円を超え
10万円以上するランドセルも
珍しくありません
でも 価格も問題にならないんです
なぜ？
でもまあ みんなが使っているから
このランドセル
子どもたちが こんなに辛くて過酷な毎日を
過ごす理由が それだけなのは
何かおかしいのではないかと感じました
いつからか 初節句にお雛様を贈るように
入学祝いに ランドセルを贈る文化が
定着しています
お祝い品ですから
より上質な良いものを贈りたいと
贈る側の祖父母の方や
ご両親は思うでしょう
年々減少する新入学生の心を
見た目でつかむために
華やかで きらびやかな装飾が付き
カラーバリエーションも豊富に揃っています
でも 現在一般的なランドセルの
外側にポケットなんてありません
硬い皮の肩ベルトで
重い荷物は さらに肩に食い込みます
６年間で30センチ以上
身長が伸びるお子さんもいる中
１年生の入学前に購入した
画一的なサイズのランドセルを
６年間使用し続けます
体に合わせて選ぶなんてこともありません
ご自身で毎日使うものに
そんなカバンを選びますか
何より 重さが ランドセルだけで
1,100から1,600グラム
1.6キロもあるんです
人は体重の15%以上の荷物を持つと
体幹に影響があると言われています
重い荷物は 成長期のお子さんの
骨や身長への悪影響も
心配されています
実際 肩こりや腰痛
背骨のゆがみなどの
深刻な症状を訴えるお子さんも
非常に増えています
「ランドセルが重いなら
送り迎えしてあげればいいよ」
と言う方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
「教科書なんて学校に
置いてきちゃえばいい」
と言う方もいらっしゃると思います
でも 送り迎えなんて
みんなができるわけじゃないですし
そういう問題じゃないんです
学校に教科書を置いてくる「置き勉」も
推奨はされましたが
実際は学校ごとの決まりが厳しく
大きく進んでいる学校は ほとんどありません
調べてみると
文部科学省や 各自治体の教育委員会で
通学カバンへの決まりがあるところは
ほとんどないことが分かりました
実際 このようなナイロン製のリュックの
ようなランドセルを使っている自治体が
全国にはいくつかあることも分かりました
でも 周りの地域にすら
波及していないんです
理由は
ランドセルからは かなり遠いデザインと
使いやすさにあるのではと感じました
ならば
自分たちで本当に使いやすくて
子どもに安心して使わせることができる
そんなランドセルを作ってみようと思いました
軽量で 大容量で
高性能リュックのように使いやすい
ナイロン製のランドセルです
重さは770グラムです
たった500グラムくらいの違いだったら
大したことないと思うでしょうか
体重が 20キロのお子さんにとっての
500グラムは
体重が40キロだったら１キロ
体重が60キロだったら
1.5キロの重さに相当します
これがカバンの重さにプラスされるんです
こう見ると結構大きいですよね
他にも 水筒を入れるポケットや
小物を入れるポケットを外側に付けたり
柔らかい肩ベルトが体にフィットして
痛みもなく 大容量で
手荷物もほとんどなくなります
「さあ このランドセルを
買ってくれたら安心ですよ」
と お話をしに来たわけではないんです
実際 販売はスタートしましたが
苦戦しています
お話をすると
「子どもたちに本当に良いのは
こういうランドセルだろうね」と
言ってくださる方が ほとんどです
なのに 選んでもらえない理由
それは
みんなと同じじゃないからです
親御さんは言うんです
「みんなと違うランドセルを使っていたら
いじめられるかもしれないよ」
それを聞いたお子さんは
「これを使ったら
いじめられるんじゃ困るなぁ」
それに
「みんなと違うものを使っている子がいたら
いじめてもいいのかな」
そう思わないお子さんはいるでしょうか
ランドセルを作る過程で
何人もの小学生のお子さんに
試作品や完成品のモニターを
お願いしました
このランドセルを使った子が
クラスに現れた時の驚き
「こんなに軽いランドセルがあるの？」
「痛くないランドセルなんてあるの？」
「こんなに荷物が入るの？」
「今まで当たり前と思って使っていた
あのランドセルは
当たり前じゃなかったの？」
ワクワクが止まらないんです
今まで自分が使っていたものに
知らなかった選択肢があって
ものをもっと自由に選べる
ということに気がついた時
それは お子さんのその後の人生にも
大きなポイントになるはずです
子どもたちが 信じ込んで我慢している
「当たり前」は 当たり前じゃないこと
ものはもっと自由に選べるということを知って
固定観念を解放して
軽やかに生き生きと
登校してほしいと そう願っていました
でも 実際スタートしてみると
大きな壁は 子どもたちの
「当たり前」の壁ではなく
大人の「みんなと同じがいい」
という壁が 私たちの前に
お子さんにたどり着く前に
大きく大きく立ちふさがりました
「みんなと違うものがいい」と
言いたいわけでは決してありません
「従来のランドセルがおかしい」と
言いたいわけでもないんです
ただ その選び方でいいんですか
ということ
自分が使うものを選ぶ
一番重要なポイントが
みんなと同じか違うか ではない
そのことに気がついて欲しいんです
お子さんも もちろん大人もです
例えば
子どもが これだけの水を
運ばなくてはいけないとなったら
どうするのがいいのか
冷静に考えて
いくつもの選択肢を
見せてあげたいと思いませんか
今日は たまたま
ランドセルの話をしましたが
実際 似たような事例は
身の回りにたくさんあるんだと思います
ちょっと見方を変えてみませんか
「なんで当たり前って
思っちゃってたんだろうね」って
よく言われるんです
選択肢が広がるのって
すっごくワクワクしますよね
そのワクワクで
子どもたちの未来が変わることを
信じています
まだ 自分で選択肢を見つけ出すことが
できない子どもたちに
広がる自由で大きな未来に
必要な一歩は
周りの大人からの一歩です
まずは あなたの周りから
ここ浜松から
子どもたちの風景を変えてみませんか
物事がより良い方向に
変わっていくことは
思っているより
簡単であって欲しいと願っています
（拍手）